[Music]
let me guess a lot of people in our
audience got a lot of young people here
they use Craigslist you guys use
Craigslist all right I want to do a
favor tonight I thought we'd help our
audience members make a sale or
connection by showing some of their
craigslist ads right here on the show
right now and actually find out what is
you're looking for it's check them out
for example there's this one guy who
killed Osama bin Laden seeking extremely
gullible woman
[Applause]
complete VHS collection of mr. Belvedere
comes with autographed photo of me
watching mr. Belvedere for sale tickets
to the Conan show for April 4th 2012 if
no one bids I guess I'll have to go just
hope they don't use me in some lame
comedy sketch
seeking girl 18
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway you walk me home
it's okay he doesn't know where he is
great free all the food you can shake
from idea
lost have you seen my fruit stand
[Applause]
wanted hot lovemaking with a woman who
finds me sexy for exactly what I am
which is a dude willing to pay for sex
and finally help meet new prom date ASAP
must be willing to travel to Jakarta
[Applause]
a little service I provide for the
people